i was living two lives one in front of
everyone at work
and family and the other behind closed
doors
where i live and it just couldn't go on
any longer
hakeem's mental health struggles stem
from abuse and
childhood trauma facing stigma from
friends and family
he lost faith in the system that was
meant to support him
we've changed his name to protect his
identity
that first counselor that i spoke to
that was the one that caused what was a
nine year delay in me actually going
back and getting the help that i know i
needed
his fears revolved around his culture
being misunderstood
i didn't want to be stereotyped i didn't
want to be labeled more than i was
already labeling myself
what i was looking for is someone that's
actually going to understand
the root of what i'm talking about where
i'm coming from
and then give me something something to
think about off the back of that
so yes i didn't trust the process i
didn't trust the system and i didn't
think that they were going to be able to
help me
nhs data shows less than 3 000 per
100 000 asian people are in touch with
mental health services
for their white counterparts this stands
at more than
four thousand uptake is lowest in the
indian community
with just over two thousand per hundred
thousand
seeking support siraj reached out for
help
after her son took his own life but
after facing
barriers and treatment she dropped out
it would have been very helpful someone
who can understand someone who can
understand my background as well at the
same time
um coming from the asian community i
just think it was more of a lack of
a book that he was more following and um
i really felt it wasn't helping me
at all i didn't feel like it's me who's
walked into this room it's me who's gone
through so much mental you know
mentally being disturbed experts say
more cultural awareness is needed within
the south asian community there's huge
stigma
around mental health we're finding that
many south asian people who
attempt to access psychological services
or any sort of mental health type
treatment it doesn't quite
match or fit their conceptual needs and
cultural needs
hakeem has managed to find support but
there are significant concerns for the
many others unable to access help
aisha zahid sky news